you know i spoke earlier of of how we
are
culturally on a collision course with a
higher dimension
and how the dimension will be fully
manifested when we
all are in it and that the psychedelic
experience is a phenomenon
which is carrying certain people toward
it
uh okay so far that's all review
the ufo is like
a collective uh psychedelic experience
which is
haunting time like a ghost
in other words the consequence of
repressing the onset of the future
is the outbreak of a symptom
of psychic disequilibrium in other words
what the flying saucer is is it's an
autonomous
portion of the mass psyche that is
adrift through time and what it's doing
is it is changing people's minds
a very interesting way of approaching
flying saucers has been developed in the
last five years
they've basically given up on what is it
where does it come from who's inside it
this has been totally unrewarding
this approach so a new approach has been
brought forward called what is it doing
we don't care what it is or where it
came from or who's inside of it
what is it doing well it turns out
you can find out what the saucer is
doing not by studying the saucer but by
studying human populations
and you discover what the saucer is
doing is number
one it's eroding people's faith in
science
this is a curious effect that the saucer
is having
the science's inability over 30 years
now to offer a convincing explanation
is causing people to believe that
scientists are stupid
and in fact that that flying saucers and
whoever is behind
them uh no more than scientists
no uh
something like 11 percent of the
american population
claim to have seen a flying saucer
that's over
one in ten something like
30 percent believe they are real
whatever that means it means you don't
believe they're not
real is what it means so and as these
statistics are clocked
as they have been since the middle 50s
the faith in the saucers is rising
it's continuously growing and it's a
millenarian kind of hysteria it's a
phenomenon of the lower classes
it is not i mean in california it may
not be because we're all such squirrels
we'll
go for anything but say in uh
say in the east or england or somewhere
like that
passionate belief in flying saucers is a
is
a
lower class phenomenon in educated
intelligent people
do not believe in flying sauces and i've
been at dinner
parties where you know everything was
going along fine and we were talking
about
the psychedelic drugs and
extraterrestrial life
and that but you mentioned flying
saucers and it's just
you believe that my good man
but i think it is it is driving a wedge
therefore between millions and millions
of people and
the official state faith of our culture
which is science now we can look back in
history to another time
when this same thing happened it is
in the phenomenon of christianity
where what you had was a an
empire of great sophistication
and great cynicism built on roman
military power and the projection of
greek philosophical ideas
the people who administered that empire
your work a day
roman administrator of the first century
we'll say
was a rationalist a materialist
a believer in democrity and atomism
somebody who offered sacrifice to the
gods but
just basically to keep his bets covered
but somebody
was pretty confident you know that
democracy and atomism epicurean
rationalism
was what was going on administering a
world girdling empire
very no-nonsense kind of operation
comes now the word that in the kitchen
jews and greeks and people of dark skin
brought in from the fringes of the
empire are talking about
some jewish rabbi some radical who rose
for the from the dead and
and and why it's just laughable it's
grotesque it's the kind of thing
servants believe
and so who needs to bother with that we
have real problems in judea
with the you know keeping down these
zealots and these
jewish radical groups with political
leanings
and so it wasn't taken seriously in a
world where
information could move only at the speed
of a horse's gallop
within 30 years it was hammering at the
gates of rome
within 120 years the emperor had to
convert
within 200 years the empire itself
was christian and and uh
hydrostatics mathematics
hydraulics engineering
these things all came to a screeching
halt
nothing was done one thing mattered
studying the words of a single jewish
rabbi
on human behavior anybody who was not
spending their time doing that had not
understood
that the good word had come from
jerusalem
and for a thousand years society
was in stasis nothing happened we just
admired the christian message and
studied its implication
now what happened and why did it happen
what happened was
that rome was a an imperial nightmare
a fascist superstate based on slavery
and exploitation of captive populations
and it was on the brink
of immense scientific breakthroughs
the mathematics of diaphantus were
probably
within 50 years could have issued into a
calculus
of some sort i mean they were probably
within 500 years of flight to the moon
when the christians reached rome and
put them through the monkey ranch so
so what happens is
that human culture is actually a
cohesive whole
and as society inevitably begins to
fall out of balance usually in the
direction
of materialism militarism and
dehumanizing tendencies of all sorts
well when that begins to happen there's
it's like a governing device
in the super ego the button is pushed
and it says
look at the dominant ideology
responsible for the cultural situation
and send a force which will turn it
upside down
for roman imperialism the flying saucer
was jesus christ
you know they had been expecting him for
centuries a messiah to arise
out of the tribes of judea and there
were people who claimed to be the
messiah and it didn't quite fit
astrologically and this way
and then finally bang somebody got the
formula right
the true messiah and the empire is swept
away
greek mystery religions are exterminated
the knowledge of the ancient world is
destroyed
the whole thing is established in the
uh patristic early christian model
now we have an even worse situation the
same thing
but on a global scale a vast imperial
force built on dehumanizing ideologies
economic enslavement manipulation of the
mass
mind through propaganda
all of the evils of modernity and
none of the ethical maturity that you
would hope would balance that out
so the cultural governor shifts into
being again
and says you know a flying saucer would
turn this scene
completely upside down and it it
is and it will we may be in the
pre-contact phase
something may come out of the mass
unconscious of the race
that will look for all the world like a
starship
from another solar system in the same
way that jesus christ
looked for all the world like god made
man
it's it's that the super ego has this
unique ability
to know the weaknesses of the mass
mind to push exactly what buttons to
push
you say super eager do you mean over
mind yeah the over
mind it knows exactly what buttons to
push to
pull a culture one way or another so i
think the message of the flying saucer
is or the purpose of the flying saucer
is to is to slow the growth of science
to allow ethics time to catch up with
it but you see it's a pitiless
historical mechanism because
i don't want to live in one of those
worlds where we all
study the words of
christ or a flying saucer i don't like
these ideologically monolithic
periods in history where everyone is so
sure they have the answer
that they go around burning out
everybody who disagrees
i think that part of the maturity of the
human species
has to do with evolving beyond the need
for these metaphysical spankings from
the superego
we need to we don't need messiahs or
flying saucers if we can become
responsible for our destiny these are
our
things used to keep children in line
and the psychedelic experience
of psychedelic drugs offer a way of
anticipating
the flying saucer getting to know it
before it arrives in a flurry
so that when it does arrive you know
what it is
and because if it should come if
our cultural imbalance is so great
that a miracle is going to be required
of the superego
when it comes all hell will break loose
i mean you can imagine the impact if
suddenly
the word was flashed that an enormous
artificial object was in orbit around
the earth
within minutes high ultra high
resolution cameras can be brought to
bear on that thing and it can be
conveyed to every television screen on
the planet
and to behold it is to lose your footing
because remember it was constructed by
the superego for the
by the overmind for the specific purpose
of getting your goat
in the same way that in the hellenistic
world when
people said have you heard about the
christians you say no what are the
christians
say they're these people and they
believe that you should love your
neighbor and
say this is weird this wrap you're
giving me is getting to me it's doing
something to my mind i'm believing it in
spite of myself
because the historical moment is so
ripe for it and science would be the
first to go i mean carl sagan all these
people would be
lined up saying yes well we always knew
the star density
by presence of biological molecules
throughout the galaxy
the drake equation we always knew that
it would be
this way you know but then i think the
saucer
would deliver the message this is how
this cultural governor works
it delivers a message and then the most
shattering part of all
is it leaves and everybody who wasn't
alive while it was here
misses it and for the next thousand
years
people say you know what was it what did
it mean
what does it mean for us what are we
supposed to do what was the message are
we getting it right are we getting it
wrong
why didn't it stay now we are be rift
again
cosmically abandoned and when will it
return
and it's just this whole childish thing
you know
about not realizing that until
society places its ethics on as high a
plane of development as its technique
or all these other things why we're
going to be subject to these
nasty surprises from the over mind
[Music]
you